and a warning his report contains
graphic images of wounds sustained by
some of the soldiers in battle
he buries his face under a cotton cap
his story kept hidden from View
but this man has seen and suffered on
the Eastern Front
facially disfigured in the Ukrainian War
Max Horowitz was offered a hospital bed
on the other side of Europe
the city of Dublin now provides
something of a century
Max can can you remove your hat
can you take your hands yeah
okay
why are you here Max
imum
um
captain horvitz and his unit were
targeted on a bridge as they tried to
repair a communication line but they
were spotted by the Russians who
attacked with artillery
foreign
did you realize that you had been
injured was it right away or did that
realization come later
um
Max blacked out and later fell into a
coma he would lose his right eye and his
skull was badly damaged
he's one of tens of thousands of
Ukrainian soldiers who've been injured
in this conflict but the authorities
won't say how many
clubs
his friends Oleg and Boris saved his
life dragging him to safety under enemy
fire this picture taken just before the
attack
foreign
he was moved from hospital to hospital
in Ukraine but the system is under
strain so the European Union has stepped
in with an unprecedented medical Airlift
Max was flown on a French jet from
Southeast Poland to a hospital in
Ireland one of two thousand seriously
injured soldiers and civilians who've
been placed at facilities around Europe
here's another
Ukrainian Yvonne nederbrook was shot
twice when his position was attacked by
Russian troops one bullet entered
through his shoulder and passed through
his spine
Ivan's been hospitalized for the past
nine months and he's trying to regain
some Mobility
at Ireland's national Rehabilitation
Hospital
forward
but it's an excruciating process better
the pain is physical and it's also
psychological Evan can no longer
tolerate the thought of War yes
will you go back to Ukraine
um
Max needs reconstructive surgery to
rebuild his face but he's had to wait
Irish hospitals are operating at full
capacity
but he does have support
his wife Tatiana and daughter Sophia
joined him in February this a joyous
moment
when Max was injured he asked Tatiana if
she'd still love him with one eye
she cried and said of course
this Journey's been hard and unexpected
the war has led them far from home
but they have a right to stay here like
all participants in the Medevac scheme
it's nice here isn't it by the Sea you
like it here
kill
him again
however Captain horvitz says he wants to
go back and fight he won't stay you will
go back
to Ukraine
he knows the risks and he suffered the
consequences of a war that is defying
resolution
but it may prove difficult to leave
these welcoming Shores
John Sparks Sky News in Dublin